no i'm a coat hanger yeah i'm not a
natural okay mesomorph the way you guys
are a couple of metamorphs in history
i'm an ectomorph yeah about mesomorphs
okay
um just naturally i'm not an endomorph
no i use i feel like an ass you're built
like an ant i built like well i got my
leg i got the legs of a frog got a bit
of a booty on me we're doing all right
there yeah you're built like the wb frog
okay
that's probably true bring that up
ginger just don't have the natural hard
for me to put on muscle yeah
you got a year you got a year yeah you
can do whatever you want to me uh-huh
you can i'll i'll take whatever you put
it's brian's body right there but is the
is there objective aesthetics do you
just want to look at that that's all we
want okay that's all we want i'm not you
want me to take it from here mark
steroids yeah
there's not a train on this earth who's
going to put muscle i i work out every
day but that nothing's going to look
exactly the same
depending on what side effects you'd
want to avoid um i don't want to die and
i don't want to know no you can take so
many steroids before you
it's insane yeah like people have this
notion of like well i'd like to i'd like
to not have it impact my longevity
ultimately like okay well there's still
a lot you can take because i like his
face get a little bloated just for my
own sake just a little water retention
oh we can do that yeah we can bloat you
up a little bit and that's one of the
side effects it's like really steroid is
all about like what side effects do you
want to avoid i'm using even more hair
right okay if you want to say [ __ ]
that's like one right you go do you want
to [ __ ] the hair or not you know what i
mean because because things like taking
for example an androlone only cycle is
one of the most hair-safe things you can
do the conventional wisdom is you don't
take nandrollin without testosterone
because you needed to convert to you
know there's this science and theory
behind it but turns out there are
certain more safe like hair safe
steroids than even testosterone you can
take testosterone and take finasteride
with it which blocks the dht conversion
you can so there's many things you can
take to mitigate i lost my blood
pressure
or just say [ __ ] all that noise and get
a wig
it makes me angry when you talk about
that no but if you're going steroids you
don't have to worry about the hair
you're never wearing a [ __ ] wig yeah
you're in my muscles just just as far as
training the hacks that i would
recommend to guys um to most guys if you
build up your your shoulders to an
insane degree and like kind of your
upper back and upper chest yeah those
are the things
when you look at the silhouette yeah you
go you want to have wide lats broad
shoulders and big upper chest so i do
like high incline
stuff for
like that machine
that's like really like gets you up high
incline yeah like because most guys
most guys do on a regular incline you're
still not quite hitting this like real
upper fiber that connects to your
shoulders
lateral raises all the time so you're
building up this part because that's
what like makes you even two inches this
way think about how dramatic that was
pretty dramatic you know yeah and you
could put two inches on my shoulder
absolutely yeah and then like as you as
you if you lost if you think about this
if you put it i'm not [ __ ] talking to
you i'm more of a real take a little bit
of fat off your stomach and add it a
little bit to your it's like for every
inch wider you get
and yeah
but i actually want to look um i don't
care about that v i want to look thicker
i want to just look okay so if you
wanted to look thick you're talking
about gold's gym stack here
jacka winston oh yeah you could take
like the upper limit of what you could
do as far as deca and still be safe
because it's like look we've talked
about like trend and stuff like that
it's just that i took a bunch of trend
not too long ago and the real effect is
like you can't work out as hard you're
almost getting like sick because of the
cardiovascular effects you know i was
taking 100 milligrams of trend a day
just i talked about this in my podcast
as like an experiment
and
like you get bigger and stronger really
quickly but you're like in the gym like
oh i feel like [ __ ] like if we did those
deadlifts today like i would have been
like
oh my god like you almost get ill
all right
so i don't want any of that [ __ ] right
because it increases your blood pressure
i got a year give me the [ __ ]
cocktail yeah give me the dough here's
what we can do for you what nothing no
no no no come on test honestly this the
most old school cycle you can do is
almost test deck a d-ball right that's
your finished
that's great it's for like it's a very
mild side effect it a little less hair
safe but it's a cosmetic effect like
think zac efron and baywatch people look
at him and go like he's on anavar if
you're really lean it makes you look
harder and kind of like not brad pitt
and fight club that's like the anavar
winstrol look it is if you were to take
something like that yeah i was like that
was sponsored by anna he's 147 pounds in
there come on yeah he talks about it
there are there's steroids like edward
norton withdrawal halo testing animals
you know what look at how this video is
there
yeah because everyone like i was reading
this thing on bodybuilding.com was a
huge fan of bodybuilding.com back in the
day and they're like everyone goes i
want to look like brad pitt from fight
club and then brad pitt came out in
interviews he's like dude i was like
starving myself i was 147 something
pounds yeah the real thing i see is just
a he's extremely lean in his way he's
looking [ __ ] troy and he has very
broad shoulders
you know
and troy he looks like he gained at
least 15 pounds
now that that's not natty no no no you
would assume that because that's his
baseline you got to realize like brad
pitt is not a naturally big guy